as you may know Consulting projects are
typically short and very challenging and
the team is always own staffed that's
probably how Consulting companies make
such a high margin per project so she
says if I understood it correctly that
she believes the pressure is so high
because the teams are underst staffed
not sure I would 100% agree with that so
I mean we just talked about that yes
there is a lot of work lots of things
lots of hours that you need to put in
but I don't necessarily agree that just
only if you would have one or two or
three additional people staffed on the
team that this would necessarily make
everyone's life easier so in like an mbb
environments if you work for a
consulting firm like BCG or Bane a
typical team size would be 2 to five
people including a Project Lead